I found myself so captivated in the way
you were delivering and I could see
you thinking the character thinking and
I go did they like what you were doing
right away in the dailies in the
beginning and you were like no well no
they didn't like it at all I mean they
worried about it yeah I would save
certain spots to pause in and not speak
and that that drove them crazy because
you know but I you know I was like this
is not radio like you can stop talking
it's okay to stop talking and by the way
you could cut it out if you want you
know it was until Dick Wolf got it like
he got it that that um people were into
that weirdness that the idea that I had
the guts enough to just pause and not
speak for a moment while that the room
is full of actors in the cameras rolling
he was the one that gave me permission
to do all of that stuff that I was
trying to do